so from this so it's interesting because
again the way women lie is they say
things that they don't know as fact so
this girl comes forward she's like well
she didn't have these opinions before
but what she didn't realize is that she
was one it was so crazy to be around and
so engulfed in her like liberal stuff
that I didn't really want to tell her
those opinions like why would I why
would I if I'm friends with someone
right why would I go out of my way to
give them an opinion on something if
that's not what we do and I know they're
stuck in there like that's what they're
gonna think and you know I personally
could be friends with people that
disagree now liberals it is not the same
boy boy